The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Alright, so last time
we started talking about
more complicated mixtures.
To get into colligative
properties.
And the example we gave was a
binary system that has two
components.
And two phases.
So we have a liquid phase
on the bottom.
A gas phase on top, and two
components, A and B, where
compositions xA and xB are
in the liquid phase.
Those are the mole fractions.
And yA and yB in the gas phase,
the mole fractions in
the gas phase.
And what we did last time was
to begin to say how many
degrees of freedom do we have,
how many variables do we need
to completely describe
this mixture.
And it turned out that for this
mixture, we only needed
two variables.
Two degrees of freedom.
We started out with four
variables; the temperature,
the pressure, and the components
in the composition
in the liquid phase and the
composition in the gas phase.
We need one of these, either
xA or xB, and one of these,
either yA or yB because
they add up to 1.
So you start with four, but
because you are in a mixture,
an equilibrium, you
have constraints.
You have the chemical potentials
that have to be
equal to each other.
The chemical potential of A in
the gas phase has to be equal
to the chemical potential of
A in the liquid phase.
And the chemical potential of
B in the gas phase has to B
equal to the chemical
potential of B
in the liquid phase.
So you start with
four variables.
Temperature, pressure, xA, yA,
then you have the constraints
that mu A, in the liquid phase
has to be equal to mu
A in the gas phase.
Because you're at equilibrium.
And mu B in the liquid phase
has to be equal to mu
B in the gas phase.
So four minus two constraints
means you have
two degrees of freedom.
And so if you want to know
everything about this mixture,
all you need is the temperature
and the total pressure.
And that's enough.
It's kind of amazing.
Give me the temperature and
pressure and these two
components, like water and
alcohol, for instance, and I
can tell you everything about
the compositions.
It's very powerful.
And then we said that this
turned out to be a special
case, or sub-case of the more
general Gibbs phase rule.
where the Gibbs phase rule tells
you that if you have C
components, in this case here
we have two, and the general
case of C components with p
phases, the number of degrees
of freedom is C minus
p plus two.
This is components.
And phases.
And where we're going to start
today is by proving this.
And then we'll do more with
this problem here.
So the first thing is for us
to prove Gibbs' phase rule.
So Gibbs phase rule.
We start out with all the
variables that we have.
And then we add the
constraints.
And for the Gibbs phase rule,
then we start with the two
knobs that we can
turn externally.
Which are the temperature
and the pressure.
So we start with temperature and
pressure, as two variables
that we have.
And then we have a
bunch of phases.
We have C phases.
And in each phase we have to
describe the composition in
that phase.
So, for each phase
alpha, we have to
describe its mole fraction.
So here we needed to describe
xA for phase A. And yA for
phase A. For component
A in the gas phase.
So now we have alpha
components.
And for each component we have
to describe its mole fraction
in that particular phase.
So we have to describe
x sub i.
But we have a constraint
on that.
The constraint is that the sum
of all the mole factions has
to be equal to one.
That's what it is, to
be a mole fraction.
So the constraint is that x sub
i, i from one to alpha, is
equal to one.
So the constraint on the number
of the components,
instead of having, actually, i
goes from one to C, because
that's the number components.
So instead of having C different
compositions that we
need to take care of, we
only need C minus one.
Just like here we only
needed one, just xA.
We didn't need both xA and xB,
because we knew the sum was
equal to one.
So that means that we really
need C minus one variables to
describe the composition
in one of the phases.
But we have p phases,
so let me fix this.
We had C components.
We have p phases.
And so for each phase, we have
to describe the composition.
So that means that we need p
times C minus one variables to
describe all the components
and all the phases,
plus these extra two.
So the total number variables
then that we start out with
before putting the fact that
we're in equilibrium, is going
to be two plus p times
C minus one.
So that's a basic description
of the system.
Then we put in the
same constraints
that we had up here.
In terms of the chemical
potentials.
If I take any of the components,
let's take the
alpha component, or the
i'th component.
Because it's in equilibrium, the
chemical potential of that
particular component has to be
the same in all the phases.
So let's take the
i'th component.
So yi in phase one has to be
equal to yi in phase two, has
to be equal to yi in phase
three, has to be equal to yi
in phase p.
All the chemical potentials have
to be the same across all
the phases for that component.
And if you count the number of
equations, the number of
equals signs here, that's p
minus one. p minus one equals
signs, constraints due to
the fact that I have an
equilibrium here.
So this gives me p minus
one constraints.
And this is true for every
single component.
Every single component has to
have its chemical potential,
its chemical potential equal
throughout the phases.
So p minus one's constraint
for one component times C
components.
So for a total of C times p
minus one total constraints.
My variables, my constraints.
So the number of degrees of
freedom then becomes p times C
minus one minus C times p minus
one and then plus two.
And if you multiply this out,
p times C gets rid of the p
times C here.
And you get the plus
C minus p plus two.
Which is the Gibbs phase
rule, right?
Which I'm going to bring
back up here.
C minus p plus two.
So just purely in accounting,
just accounting for the
variables and the constraints.
OK, any questions on
how we did this?
Great.
OK.
So let's move on, then, to
these ideal solutions.
Which is this case right here.
And the first thing we're going
to do is look at the
case where we have A is a
solvent, and it's volatile.
And B is a solute, which
is non-volatile.
So let's take the first case.
We have A volatile,
that's a solvent.
Could be water.
And B is going to
be the solute.
It's non-volatile.
And let's interchange solute
or non-volatile to be
consistent here.
So this could be sugar.
A sweet water.
So, Mr. Raoult looked at such
solutions, and found that they
could be well described by the
following diagram here.
So if I plot on the x-axis here,
from zero to one, I'm
going to plot the partial molar
fraction of the solute.
Partial molar fractions of the
solute, that's going to be xB.
So when xB equals to zero, I
have a pure water solution.
When xB is equal to one,
I have pure sugar.
Then on the y axis, I'm going
to plot the total pressure.
So when I have a pure water
solution, the total pressure
is going to be the same as the
vapor pressure of water at a
particular temperature.
Let's take temperature
fixed at some value.
Temperature is fixed
at some value.
I'm going to have the total
pressure is going to be the
partial pressure of the water.
And clearly, when I don't have
any water left, all I have is
the sugar, there's
no pressure.
We're going to assume that it's
totally non-volatile.
Obviously there's going to
be a little bit of vapor
pressure, even at room
temperature.
Ten to the minus, I don't know,
13 torr or something.
But anyway, it's basically
zero here.
And what Raoult said is that
while these two points are
just connected by
a straight line.
Simplest way to connect
two points.
Basically, he said that the
pressure of, the vapor
pressure of the water in
this case, is equal
to xA times pA star.
I could also plot this with xA,
going from one to zero,
since xA plus xB is
equal to one.
Or I could write this as one
minus xB times pA star.
Where a star, the star,
means pure water.
So pure A. And pA is the vapor
pressure of the mixture.
Which in this case here is the
total pressure, because I
don't have anything else
that's volatile.
And this is Raoult's law.
And the first thing that you can
use this for is to look at
your first colligative property
which is vapor
pressure lowering.
And let me point out another
thing first.
So if a solution obeys that
property here, it's called an
ideal solution.
So if the water-sugar solution
really did behave like a
straight line like this, as
you increase the amount of
sugar, then it would be
an ideal solution.
Many things are very
close to it.
It's not such a bad
approximation.
Especially in that
region up here.
Around zero, when the amount
of sugar is pretty small.
You expect to obey an ideal
solution behavior.
Alright, so let's look now at
a glass of water that has
sugar in it.
We've got my glass
of water, H20.
With some sugar dissolved
in it.
And it's got a certain vapor
pressure on top. pA, or pH2O.
And I'm going to ask the
question, what's the
difference between the vapor
pressure what it would be
without the sugar in it.
What is pA star minus pA?
Obeys Raoult's law. pA star,
pA is xA pA star,
plug that in here.
That's one minus xA pA star,
one minus xA is xB.
xB pA star.
Well, the first thing I know
is that this is a positive
number. xB is a positive
number. pA star
is a positive number.
This is greater than zero.
That means that the act of
putting some solute in my
water decreases the vapor
pressure of the
water in the gas phase.
Pretty simple.
It's called vapor
pressure law.
And we can actually take
this one step further.
We can draw a phase diagram.
So our usual phase diagram here
with temperature on this
axis here and pressure on this
axis here, and we've got our
triple point sitting here.
And our gas-liquid line, with
a critical point here.
So this is gas here, there's
a liquid here.
And we've got our, this
is going to be water.
So it's got a negative slope.
I think I've got it
right this time.
And there's the solid
phase here.
OK, this is for the
pure stuff.
So now I can draw a similar
diagram for sugared water.
And I just looked at
this, assuming it
obeys Raoult's law.
What we looked at here was the
gas-liquid coexistence.
And we found that the gas-liquid
coexistence point,
the vapor pressure of
the water, was less
than if it were pure.
So that means that if I looked
at the gas-liquid coexistence,
which is this line right here.
In the presence of sugar,
that whole line is
going to get lowered.
The pressure, the vapor
pressure, of the water is
going to be lower when
the sugar is there.
So the whole thing is
going to get lower.
Now, if I have a solid, if the
water is a solid, it's going
to crystallize the water, the
sugar is going to be separated
from the water.
The sugar and the water are not
going to really know about
each other.
They're just going to have big
chunks of pure water, with
every now and then a molecule
of sugar that's in there.
So you don't really expect to
see any difference between the
pure solid water, in terms of
the gas-solid interface, and
the pure liquid water.
There's no sugar in
the gas phase.
And as far as the gas phase is
concerned, that solid phase is
pure water.
It's just seeing pure ice
crystals on the surface.
Every now and then there's
a molecule of sugar.
So you expect this to be
pretty close here.
So you expect the triple
point to go down.
And if I now, I go up to the
solid-liquid coexistence, and
go up like this, I can make a
prediction about solid-liquid
coexistence.
I can predict that if I'm
looking at, let's put one bar
here somewhere.
One bar.
Room temperature, sitting
here somewhere.
One bar, room temperature,
water is all liquid.
This is what it would usually,
solid, liquid, that would be
273 degrees Kelvin.
That's the melting
point of water.
So now if I put sugar in the
water, and I follow my diagram
here, what I find is that the
new melting point of water is
some new temperature T, T1,
where T1 is less than 273
degrees Kelvin.
You all know this.
When you put something, like an
impurity, a salt or sugar
in the water, the melting
point gets depressed.
It goes down.
Straight from here.
You can build it up straight
from here.
When we get to the colligative
properties, we'll attack it
from the point of chemical
potentials.
We'll equate chemical potentials
and we'll look at
the change in the chemical
potential in the water, and
the presence of the sugar and
we'll do it rigorously.
But this is sort of the first
indication that these
colligative properties are all
connected to each other.
They're connected to
this diagram here.
OK.
So when I was a kid, and I knew
that this was the case.
Everybody knows this
is the case, right?
You put salt in the water
and you expect all sorts
of things to happen.
You expect the vapor pressure
to go down.
And certainly you know that you
add salt to the roads and
the water melts, et cetera.
And my mother always told me
that the reason why you added
salt to the water was so that
the temperature of the water
would get higher when you
try to boil pasta.
And for, I don't know, fifteen
years I believed her.
Until I taught thermodynamics.
And I actually calculated the
change in the temperature by
adding a few pinches of
salt to the water.
And you know how small that
temperature change is?
You should calculate it.
It's really tiny.
It won't make any difference
for the water.
Probably the difference in the
temperature of the water will
be the same as if I cooked here
versus halfway up Mount
Washington in New Hampshire
or something.
Probably even less.
There's no difference.
The reason why you add salt is
so that it tastes better.
That's the only reason.
It has nothing to do with
thermodynamics.
Alright, any questions
on this?
So we going to make it a little
bit more complicated
now, if there's no questions.
We're going to now have,
instead of having one
non-volatile solute, use we're
going to have two, we're going
to have this mixture.
Where both components
are volatile.
Can we erase this?
Actually, I may not
erase this.
Because I want to keep
Raoult's law here.
OK, we're going to have a
mixture of two volatile
components.
For instance, water
and alcohol.
Your your typical martini
type situation.
Or margarita.
Whatever's your favorite
drink.
So now we have xA, we have xB,
we have yA, we have yB.
And we're going to assume that
both obey Raoult's law with
respect to each other.
So now if I draw a diagram,
and I just focus on, so
there's the total pressure
sitting here.
And I just focus on
one component
and ignore the other.
Suppose I focus on A. And I know
that A in the presence of
B, the partial pressure of A is
going to obey Raoult's law.
And let's take A to be the more
volatile component in
this case here.
So pA star is bigger
than pB star.
The partial pressure, pure A,
had a particular temperature,
T fixed is bigger than pB star,
it's the more volatile
of the two.
So if I were to plot pA as a
function of xB, going from
zero to one, so it'll be
Raoult's law, I'm going to
start at pA star.
And I'm going to go down
linearly to xB equals one.
Now I can do the same thing for
the partial pressure of B.
And assume that in the presence
of A, just looking at
this component B, now, and I'm
looking at the partial
pressure of B, and it's got its
impurity in it, A. B obeys
Raoult's law with A in there.
But now if I want to keep the
same x axis here, I can look
at xA here, going from
zero to one.
So I just basically flip
the thing over.
So at xA equals zero that's
pure B. pB star is
less than pA star.
I'm starting here, on that side
here. pB star, and I'm
going down in a straight line to
zero. pB is equal to xB pB
star, straight line all
the way to zero when
xB is equal to zero.
So that's pB.
And that's pA.
Now, the total pressure is the
sum of the two. pA plus pB.
So the total pressure in this
system here, that I measure
here, is just the sum of these
two straight lines.
Let me do it in blue.
The total pressure, if you add
up these two straight lines
together, you got another
straight line.
Two straight lines make a
straight line. p is pA plus pB
is equal to xA pA star
plus xB pB star.
Now, xA and xB are related.
xB is one minus xA.
And so really, this is only a
function of one variable here.
Linearly, with respect
to one variable.
OK, what does this
diagram tell me?
So now, let's ignore
how we built it.
And let's take a look at it.
So I have, going to take
xB on the bottom here.
From zero to one.
We could choose either one, and
I've got the straight line
for the total pressure going
from pA star to pB star.
T is fixed.
I need to tell you that T is
fixed because I have two
degrees of freedom, right?
I have two degrees of freedom.
My degrees of freedom are the
temperature, which I'm fixing.
And the composition
in the liquid
phase, which I'm fixing.
So my two variables are
xB and T. Those are my
two degrees of freedom.
And I'm telling you what
the total pressure is.
I'm giving you total pressure as
a function of xB and T. By
fixing T, I'm really telling
you what the pressure is of
the function of xB.
So the Gibbs phase rule then
tells me that the pressure
should be only a function
of xB if T is fixed.
Should be a line.
Not necessarily straight,
but it should be a
line in this diagram.
To have coexistence.
So what this line is, then,
this line is the line of
points that tells me when I have
coexistence between the
gas phase and the
liquid phase.
The coexistence line.
This is the gas-liquids
coexistence
line for the mixture.
It's not so different than this
coexistence line up here.
So you can think of this as a
phase diagram, kind of like
you thought, you know this
as a phase diagram.
It's got a coexistence line.
And then if I'm above this
line, if I'm at a certain
pressure here, I'm at this
point here, this pressure
well, let's go to a
slightly higher
different pressure here.
And this composition here.
I'm not on the line.
That means that I don't
have coexistence
between liquid and gas.
I'm above the line.
I'm at a pressure higher then
where I would get coexistence.
The pressure is higher,
means I probably don't
have a gas any more.
Probably means that the total
pressure pushing down on my
mixture is too high to have
a gas phase around.
It means that the top part
here is a liquid phase.
So I'm in the liquid phase if
I'm above this line and I have
a coexistence between the
gas and the liquid
if I'm on the line.
Now, if I'm below this line
here, well, I get in trouble.
I get in trouble because my
first instinct would be, well
this is just gas.
I go from liquid, and then
I have coexistence.
Then I go into the gas phase.
But my x-axis here is
the composition
in the liquid phase.
There's no liquid around.
So I really can't say
anything here.
This diagram is a little bit
meaningless down here.
Because my x-axis is describing
a phase which
doesn't exist on the diagram.
On this diagram, here.
So when you see it, this diagram
here with Raoult's law
on it, you've got to remember
that the part that's really
interesting is above the line
and at the line itself.
So you could do an experiment,
then, on this line here.
T fixed.
This is the liquid phase.
So suppose I start
with some high
pressure up here somewhere.
At this point, let's call
this point one.
We've got my container, my
piston here. p is equal to p1.
Again, I put the point
in an awkward place.
Let's put it right there.
p1, and composition xB.
p1 and xB here.
And I'm going to slowly
decrease the pressure.
I start in this composition.
The composition doesn't
change.
I'm just decreasing
the pressure.
Decrease the pressure, decrease
the pressure,
decrease the pressure.
And at some point, I
get to that line.
Get to that line, what happens
when I get to that line?
I start to see bubbles coming
out of the liquid.
Vapor starts to form, because
it wants to be in the
coexistence line.
So I get to that line.
And I get a little bit
of bubbles forming.
And a little bit of vapor.
That's the liquid here.
Little bit of gas.
And that's why this line here
is called the bubble line.
So I've gone down, decreased
the pressure.
So p has gone down now.
Decreased the pressure.
And if I keep on decreasing
pressure, well, I'm not going
to jump into this area
of the diagram.
Because this area of the diagram
means there's no
liquid, it's a meaningless
area.
If I keep decreasing the
pressure, I'm still going to
be in coexistence.
I'm just going to
make more gas.
More vapor.
I'm going to transfer
more of the liquid
into the vapor phase.
I'm going to ride
down that line.
down the line.
I'm decreasing the pressure.
I'm not going to
skip into here.
I'm going to ride down
the line here.
We're going to keep decreasing
the pressure even more. p goes
down even more.
Now, I make even more vapor.
There's my piston right there.
There's the gas phase.
There's the liquid phase.
Now I've transferred material
from the liquid
phase to the gas phase.
But I also changed
the composition
of my liquid phase.
And if I read my new
composition, this is what I
started out with. xB.
My new composition in the liquid
phase is going to be,
let's call it xB prime.
There's going to be more
solute in there.
Or more B in there, than what
I started out with.
Now which one was the
more volatile one?
A or B?
A was more volatile, right?
So as I decreased the pressure
and I started bubbling off the
material, which one's going to
bubble off preferentially?
A is going to.
So it makes sense that I would
concentrate B in there.
Decrease the pressure.
Bubbles that are rich
in A come out.
Both A and B come out.
But more A comes out than B. And
what's left over is rich
and then more than the less
volatile material which is B.
So we're beginning to see how
distillation comes about.
This is the first step in it.
In a distillation process.
So let's make this a little
bit more complicated now.
Any questions, first?
Alright, now, suppose
I wanted to know.
So I found out where the
composition in the liquid
phase is here.
And I know that should tell
me immediately whether the
composition in the gas
phase is here.
So I have all, I have everything
I need to know to
calculate what the composition
in the gas phase is.
So I have everything I need,
then, to calculate and draw a
diagram that looks
just like this.
Except where my x-axis is the
y's instead of the x's.
Going to make the same diagram,
except now I'm going
to use the gas phase as
my reference point.
The composition in
the gas phase.
So I need to get, so here I
got p as a function of xB.
I want p, total pressure,
as a function of yB.
So I can draw a diagram that
looks just like this except
now with the x-axis being the
gas phase composition.
Let's turn the crank.
What do I know?
I know Dalton's law. pA is
yA times total pressure.
I'm trying mix up the partial
pressures and the total
pressure in all ways that
I know how to write it.
And then hope that something's
going to come out that's going
to be helpful.
So that's Dalton's law.
I know Raoult's law. pA is
xA star times pA star.
And that's Raoult.
And I can write Raoult's
law in a different way.
I can write as pB is equal to
xB pB star, that's just
Raoult's law for B. One
minus xA pB star.
And I'm looking for this.
I'm looking for the composition
in the gas phase.
Or the total pressure as a
function of the composition in
the gas phase.
Let's start by finding the
composition in the gas phase
as a function of
the composition
in the liquid phase.
And the total pressure.
Rewrite yA is equal to
pA over P. Total
pressure is pA plus pB.
Sum of the two partial
pressures. pA over pA plus pB.
And I'm trying to get yA
in terms of the xA's.
Or xB's, in terms
of composition
in the liquid phase.
And I know how to relate
that to a constant.
Which is the vapor pressure of
the pure material times the,
and the composition of the
liquid phase, Raoult's law.
This is xA pA star divided by
xA pA star plus xB pB star.
And I know that xB
is one minus xA.
So this is xA pA star times pB
star plus pA star minus pB
star times xA.
Where all I did was replace
xB with one minus xA.
And rearrange my equation
on the bottom.
So I've gotten the composition
in the gas phase in terms of
the composition in
the liquid phase.
They're not independent.
I knew they weren't
independent.
And this just shows me
that math works.
OK.
So I've got that.
And I can invert this to get the
composition in the liquid
phase in terms of the
composition in the gas phase.
It's not so straightforward,
but you can get xA as a
function of yA, as well.
You've got xA, if you reverse
this you get xA is
equal to yA pB star.
It looks kind of the same. pB
star plus pA star plus pB star
minus pA star times yA. xA
as a function of yA.
Alright.
So now you can actually put
everything together, starting
from Dalton's law.
Because really what we want
is the total pressure as a
function of the composition
in the gas phase.
So there's our total
pressure here.
There's the composition
in the gas phase.
There's pA.
We've found composition in
the gas phase in terms of
composition in the
liquid phase.
P is equal to yA over pA.
Which is equal to yA
over xA pA star.
So if we could get rid of
this here, in terms of
yA, we'd be all set.
We'd get the total pressure as
a function of the composition
in the gas phase.
And there's what we need.
So we plug that in here.
And now we have the total
pressure in terms of constants
like these pure vapor pressures
and the composition
of A in the gas phase.
So let me find a way to
write that somewhere.
Let me write it right here
in this little box here.
Plug it in, you get something
that's not a straight line.
Unfortunately.
Doesn't look like Raoult's law.
pA star pB star. pA star
plus pB star minus
pA star times yA.
It's not a straight line.
It's a more complicated
function.
What does it look like?
Looks like this.
I'm going to use the
same sort of plot.
I going to plot the total
pressure on this axis here, on
the y axis.
I'm going to keep the T fixed.
Temperature is fixed.
So I'm going to find the total
pressure as a function of the
composition in the gas phase.
I'm going to put yB here. yB
going from zero to one.
So it's kind of looking like
what I had before.
Total pressure is going
to look the same.
If you want to do it in terms of
B, you just have everywhere
you see B replace it with A.
And everywhere you see A
replace it with B. You just
need to change the two.
You know that if yB is equal to
zero, that you have pure A.
So you know that this is going
to be pA star here.
You know if you have yB equals
to one in the gas phase, you
have pure B in the gas phase.
You know that what you have is
the vapor pressure of the pure
B, in this case the pure
water. pB star, OK?
Where A is more volatile then B.
A would be the ethanol and
B would be the water.
And it's not a straight line.
If it were Raoult, he would
say just connect these two
with a straight line.
But it's not.
It's not, we just figured out
with an equation here.
And it turns out to be a line
that looks like this.
It's a curved line that
looks a bit like this.
OK, what does this line mean?
This line is also a
coexistence line.
That's what we started
out with.
We started out with Raoult.
That was part of
our derivation.
Raoult's law tells you the
composition at coexistence.
Tells you the pressure of, the
total pressure, or partial
pressure at coexistence
and the composition.
So this is a coexistence
line between the
liquid and the gas.
Coexistence between
liquid and gas.
But now, it's not as a function
of the composition at
the liquid phase.
It's a function of the
composition in the gas phase.
Which was missing before.
So now if I do my experiment,
and I'm, so
what does this mean?
So if I have a point, if I have
a pressure which is lower
than the line here, then
I have pure gas.
Pressure, low pressure,
Don't have any liquids.
And that's fine, because
I can, I know
what that point is.
If I'm sitting below the
line here somewhere,
so I'm sitting here.
Some composition in the gas
phase, a certain pressure.
That's fine.
It's a meaningful point.
So my container here
has a piston on it.
And I'm starting out with
this pressure, p1 here.
p1 pressing down.
And I got yB in this here.
And I increase the pressure,
pressure goes up.
Composition doesn't change.
I'm just increasing
the pressure.
Increasing the pressure,
increasing the pressure.
Now, at some point the pressure
becomes big enough
that I start to see
liquid forming.
Little drops of liquid forming
in my container.
So now I have little drops of
liquid that are forming in my
container, that are going to
start to rain down and form a
little bit of liquid
pooling at the
bottom of the container.
And that's called
the dew line.
The other one was called the
bubble line, this is called
the dew line.
So when I reach the dew line,
I start forming liquid.
And again, just like in the
previous case, if I keep
increasing the pressure, I don't
go into this area here.
First of all, this area's
meaningless for
this diagram here.
Because this area's
pure liquid.
But the x-axis here doesn't tell
me about the composition
of pure liquid.
It's all yB.
It's all about the composition
in the gas -- yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Between the dew
line and the bubble line?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This never,
never world.
Where you're not allowed
to inhabit.
We're going to go into
that next time.
On how to use those two
curves together.
OK, but the same thing
happens here.
If I increase the pressure,
I'm going to ride the
coexistence line up.
I ride it up, and keep
riding it up.
And I get liquid forming
in here.
And I can find out the
composition in
the gas phase now.
The composition in the gas
phase, as I increase the
pressure, I get yB prime,
there's yB that I
started out with with.
With yB prime is less than yB.
And remember, B was the less
volatile of the two.
As I increase the pressure,
I am forming liquid.
The composition in the
gas phase changes.
You decrease the mole fraction
of the less volatile material
in the gas phase.
The more volatile
A becomes more
prevalent in the gas phase.
And what's coming down is
mostly, then, it's enriched in
B. You've done an enrichment of
the less volatile material
down in here.
And now you can put the
two together, as the
question was asked.
Now we can have, we mix
the two together.
We mix our Raoult diagram with
our dew line diagram.
We mix the bubble line and
the dew line together.
In one diagram, which
is going to be a
powerful diagram to use.
Total pressure.
Temperature fixed.
You've got two materials, pA
star is bigger than pB star.
So I'm going to have pA star
here, pB star down here.
And if I choose, as my x-axis,
to have xB going from zero to
one, I can draw a coexistence
line on this axis.
On this diagram.
That's the coexistence
line in terms of xB.
And any point up here is
well-described by this xB
value, and the p value.
And as long as I have xB here,
I'm not allowed to touch the
bottom part of this diagram.
But now if I add another x-axis,
I'm going to add yB.
From zero to one.
I draw a coexistence line
in terms of yB.
Like this.
So this line is p
as a function of
yB coexistence line.
This line is total pressure
of function of xB.
And as long as I'm on this line
or below this line, then
this axis makes sense.
That's how we build
this diagram here.
It's got a bubble line
on top, and the
dew line on the bottom.
So I'm up here going down, I'm
going to hit the bubble line.
If I'm down here and go up
in pressure, I'm going
to hit the dew line.
And next time -- well, next
time we have an exam.
But on Friday, we'll figure out
how to use this diagram.